foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
I see you guys in there talking all that
smack we ain't even late yet fam it's
two minutes till five
so calm yourself
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we have returned I got I got I got dirt
with me man I got dirt with me Ed and it
looks like we're not gonna be reacting
because uh you know uh it's not an
actual live stream so I'm gonna fix that
real quick it looks like it's a live
stream it was on
oh it was actually on yeah yeah I'll
just watched the uh I just watch Silent
Hill too
was it look any good yeah it looks good
so you know we could talk we could start
off with that dirt you know welcome to
the attic show we talk about the past
present future gaming we got too much to
talk about to do some intros let's go
straight into Silent Hills hey hey Dart
you was telling me what's it say at the
end of that trailer
uh PlayStation 5 console exclusive uh
it's a timed exclusive for 12 months
which is obviously uh entire year and I
honestly addict I have no problem with
that it's just business right
but the issue I have is hypocrisy that's
the word of the day ladies and gentlemen
hypocrisy but go ahead and you know the
funny thing I'm gonna put the time
stamps for 13.50 when the show started
the funny thing about this whole thing
is they like they be acting like
that it
it this doesn't happen like I'm sorry
I'm gonna be real with you guys be real
brother Sony are some con they're
walking contradictions absolutely it's
it's crazy that they get away with this
stuff and what's funny is they're going
out there saying that they can't compete
but they're locking stuff up like that
so it's just like you know you could
compete but you wouldn't I honestly you
know correct me if I'm wrong Dirk I
honestly feel like the reason Sony does
this stuff they do is because they don't
want to nurture outside of the stuff
they normally make so when it comes to
getting like the personas the Call of
Duty marketing rights they want to rely
on those to exceed their brand and not
make stuff to rival those so when
Microsoft started buying this stuff they
get nervous because it's not their cup
of tea and if it took off the chess
board facts
after Silent Hill
Microsoft buy more stuff
because because I I I feed myself off of
the uh the people in the chat they say
stupid stuff like they don't do this
like and what's crazy is you see a lot
of the you know the Fanboys agree you
know they might not come out there
openly and say it but you see they agree
and that's the sad part about it man we
are live on the attic show what's funny
is uh because I was eating right before
the podcast
that's why uh it took me a couple
minutes to get everything going
because I told my girl to pick up some
Chinese and she was uh she never looked
at her phone and I ordered it and she
didn't know that so she ordered
something completely different oh so I
had to drive all the way back up there
and get it
uh so that's why I was you know a little
late but you know
I think it's funny yeah there's not a
whole lot to talk about in terms of this
I do feel like with these timed
exclusives and the worst part dirt is
they could they can extend
very easily and they did it with a
destiny they they're very vocal about
making that a Time exclusive it's sad
okay and the reason it's sad is because
a lot of the time these people don't
deserve it you know and it has been
rumored for a while that they were going
to get an exclusive uh Silent Hill it's
kind of funny it took this long to get
it yeah Silent Hill 2 remake or whatever
they're not even calling it a remake
from what I saw it's just Silent Hill
too
um
but like I said I wholeheartedly agree
with everything that you're saying
it's it's business so I understand why
Sony is doing it but I just can't get
over the hypocrisy of them like they
have the audacity to sit here and
complain about and tell Xbox what they
should or should what they can or can't
do with Activision Blizzard and the Call
of Duty franchise once they acquire them
and then they're crying they're
complaining and then they constantly do
stuff like this like I said I'm going to
say this one more time I personally I
have no problem with them signing timed
exclusive deals I have no problem with
that that's business
but
don't get mad because Xbox is about to
buy activism blizzard and now you're
being Hypocrites I I just can't stand
that man so this game being the time
exclusive cool whatever cool out of
curiosity what's the Studio's name
you know it's funny I see people posting
this uh
this game all over Twitter right now
saying oh it's an exclusive but it's
just like when the Witch Hunt won what
was that the uh the one that was out on
uh Game Pass and I think it was an
exclusive the witch trial no the witch
trial thing the last game blooper made
uh someone in the chat correct me I know
one of you guys gonna correct me you
guys love doing that one of you guys uh
Blair Witch that's what it was Blair
Witch okay yeah yeah they they were
talking mad smack about that game when
it came out but now I guess they make
they make AAA quality games man of
course yeah yeah and hopefully you know
hopefully they've learned from some of
the mistakes they made in the Blair
Witch and they make Silent Hill
fantastic game I hope the game does well
because you like the media I couldn't
get down on it you couldn't get into too
much yeah yeah
I just I think because Silent Hill is
such a popular title it would be nice
for for that game to have a happy ending
you know yeah uh but you know let's go
ahead and move on to the actual topics
uh welcome to the action we talked about
the past present and future game I got
my co-host with me Dirk griggity what
you've been playing Dart
well recently I've I started playing
style Requiem last night love it so far
I love the first one even before Game
Pass I bought it um when I saw a trailer
if I said this game looks pretty good so
I'm loving the sequel so far I also been
playing um
it's like a uh what's like what you call
them like a real movie for motion video
games called in immortality that it's
okay so it's it's a little weird I
finished it I think it's I don't even
know if I finish it or not bro it's like
I got a nice big achievement for at the
end uh so that was about it
um I'll be playing something outside
here I think of it right now oh I
started playing Horizon forbidden West
again put it back down it's a pretty
game but I can care less about it I'm
not just being an Xbox right now it's
just
it's a beautiful game but it's just a
little slow for me
um but that's about it man I'm waiting
for Friday I'm going to play that FPS
that 30 FPS got them Knights
oh you gonna play that yeah I'm gonna
buy it man well good for you man good
for you uh I'm actually waiting for
Persona 5 to hit to hit that uh that's
fine yeah it's Friday I'm uh probably
streaming on the gaming attic channel so
definitely go follow that I'm trying to
do different stuff on gaming addict I
don't know if it's gonna work because my
thing is I get two burnt out so quickly
on certain things that I want to do
something different I got to be better
at like sticking to a script if that
makes sense so we got some good
good information for you guys I think
you guys are going to enjoy it so you
know we're going to start off with this
crazy drama that's going on with
Bayonetta tell me tell me you've kept up
with this too to a point
um a little bit
yeah this is like one of those classic
things where it's like you know wait
till you hear both sides before you
start going out there with the
pitchforks so for those who don't know I
think Helen I don't remember her last
name but she
I think her name was Helen I don't know
but she she is the Alina I think that's
it Alina so she is the Alina is it is it
Taylor
uh I don't know she is the uh the leader
one second
she's the leader oh well she's the voice
actress for uh Bayonetta and Bayonetta
three is her name Bayonetta or is the
game just called but you know
I have no idea yeah I don't play pain
medicine
she did the first two and then when it
comes around to the third one she came
out on Twitter and said they only
offered her measly four thousand dollars
to do the whole roll yeah I think they
said it was four days worth of work so
maybe like 15 hours or something like
that right so it's just like okay
first off
I still think even though let's let me
go and explain the whole situation what
ended up happening is
everything went crazy uh it went through
all social media
rightfully so four thousand dollars to
play Someone Like Bayonetta and keep in
mind this isn't like a mad successful
game either it did have a little bit of
success but it's not like a GTA 5 right
but you know she she wanted them
demanding like I think they said like a
hundred grand power up or something like
that
yeah she probably shouldn't have
demanded six figures for that game
yeah so you know I think the end of the
issue we have here
is
afterwards they came out and they said
look we didn't offer her just four
thousand dollars we offer four thousand
dollars a session and they said it was
like three or four days worth of work so
it all should be getting like 15 grand
now I want to ask you a question Dirk
because yeah
for for a game that made for us a
franchise that made 450 million dollars
of both of them it's not just one so the
whole thing do you kind of think that
even 15 grand to play the main The Voice
act the main character might be a little
bit I know people that host hosts for
like you know how like you know Paris
Lily and all them like the host events I
know people that host events like that
making like 20 stacks
do you think that it's kind of
ridiculous for fifteen thousand dollars
to to voice act the game I personally
feel like look she should have been more
vocal about what was going on and the
issue that she was having
but she shouldn't have held some of that
information just to look to make them
look worse I actually personally feel
like she just killed her career
really well yeah yeah like going public
with it like that yeah there's certainly
a possibility you broke NDA and now it's
looking like you broke NDA just because
you wasn't happy with the pay and what
that's going to look like is you have
other agencies it's like oh do we take
her on knowing that something like this
can happen just because if they don't
come to an agreement on pay right and
especially with something like voice
acting they can just find somebody else
to do the damn you know I'm saying it's
not like you know you see them or yeah
it's crazy
so
that's my issue my issue with this is
like
you should have been better on
communication there should be a lot more
Community you should have been
transparent you should have took the
approach look this is what they offered
me I don't think I I think I'm worth
more than four thousand dollars a day
for four days uh and then go from there
well the one of the biggest issues I had
from her I don't know how you feel dirt
I don't like the way she went out there
over after Jennifer hell she has no
right uh you know being signing posters
as Bayonetta like first off
I don't know because I'm not 100
familiar with this but I'm guarantee you
that this individual didn't write the
character of Bayonetta so yeah to me how
are you going to tell them that wrote
the character for bayonet you just
played the voice that someone else
doesn't have the right first off you
don't even have the right you just voice
you didn't even write you didn't even
make the character you just voiced them
yeah I agree bro she's um
she's coming off as a entitled crybaby
like kind of and like you said she I
mean she might she she she I think she
did hurt herself especially like going
after the voice actress that replaced
her
I'm pretty sure the voice actors didn't
call Platinum like look y'all fire give
me the roll right now you know no I'm
sure they asked her to replace
um Helena Taylor so for her to act like
that man I don't you know and at first
when everything first came out people
was kind of on her side because you know
like you don't we didn't because she
only told half the story it looks like
yeah yeah so people like even I was like
yeah man like playing them on some BS
but once everything came out you're like
oh okay that is always three sides to
every story right uh but
I don't know man you know I'm sorry go
ahead I do think we can have a
conversation on whether or not these
voice actors that bring these characters
to life are getting underpaid and I
think that's been a conversation we've
been having for a while because it's
like I said even though that that's
still like I think someone did the math
it's like 200 300 an hour for the amount
of work they asked her to do four
thousand dollars a day oh no that was
just when we thought it was four
thousand dollars a period right uh so
it's like look like maybe her issue
isn't necessarily getting paid how often
she gets asked to do a job uh you know I
think I think uh because I was watching
um
I think it was wiper well and they were
going over like all the stuff that she's
done she hasn't really done much since
Bayonetta 2. yeah so maybe that showed
that maybe that scream stuff right there
if you haven't been asked to work since
2014 or something in that game but she
did the Super Smash Brothers stuff but
it doesn't seem like she she gets asked
to do much yeah uh listen Maybe that's
intentional because she is difficult
like you'll know what she's hard to work
with I remember I brought up an um IOP I
remember when people were saying Wesley
Snipes was hard to work with the Blade
franchise and uh you know he they ended
up you know obviously I think they would
continue the franchise with them if all
the stuff wouldn't happen with him but
it's just like look like
if you were too hard to deal with for a
certain amount of time they will get rid
of you and they have no problem bro uh
like yeah they say where's your science
is very difficult on blade Trinity
not one and two but Blade Trinity he was
extremely difficult they said he uh
the only scenes that he would do I
actually saw the only things that Wesley
Snipes would do was scenes that showed
his face anything else he he used his
body double it was extremely difficult
you know they said he would use his body
double in every scene except for scenes
where he had to talk
yeah it's just like okay I got 10 super
drive from Donna talk everyone who jumps
to conclusions added I jumped on the
boycott train addict what are we always
talking about me uh needs to go buy two
copies of beta three also there's no way
the beta franchise made 450 million
dollars I don't know what that made I'm
not gonna act like I don't know what
that means and I but I honestly do feel
like the person who played bayonet would
know that information
so regardless if she's telling the truth
they're not a little care don't want to
talk Donald taku
I if you if you listen to me on IOP
I I I encourage you don't want to talk
go listen to me on IOP I said very
vocally multiple times if she is telling
the truth on her side
then yes it needs to be happening
because if it was only four thousand
dollars four just four
that is a spit in the face that that's
why I felt like they were trying to get
rid of her it wasn't about the money
they knew she wouldn't take it but we
know more information I only went off
the information we had
so yeah Donald talking but yeah I think
when it comes to this like look
I think she might have just killed her
career
uh but unfortunately if you look at what
she got paid it doesn't look like she
she had much of a career I know it
sounds really bad but yeah it is what it
is though it's just like
all I know is when when you when you're
good
you work good people like you you you
get jobs
but it does seem like maybe she wasn't
easy to work with and if yeah their
mindset was like if we're going to pay
you it's it's going to be on the cheap
side uh yeah a minute
it was like Jeremy Brown shared in the
uh chat when you have a history of being
difficult people will stop calling you
like he used the example Edward Norton
incredible actor incredible actor you
don't see him he's a really hard actor
to work with uh they said he would try
to be the director and eventually
Hollywood stop calling him man you know
so so like once you get that stigma that
you're difficult to work with in any uh
business whether it's movies TV video
games you will stop getting calls so if
she hasn't done anything since Bayonetta
2
I don't know that's something to look at
man that's something to look at and
that's for a reason that's just the
individual in the podcast was uh was
correct I think
my issue with the whole matter is like
how you gonna come out and say don't
support anything related to that how you
gonna come out there and say that person
doesn't have the right to sign posters
as Bayonetta like and how are you going
to sit there and say if they make a
sequel don't support it
like it's just
the the consequences that that's like
equivalent
to you know when Johnny Depp got kicked
out of the uh what's the for the Harry
Potter franchise the the the prequels
uh Harry Potter yeah the prequels what
were they called I know the chat knows
oh the um
I can't think of the name but I know the
ones you're talking about they just
released Another one not so long ago
yeah because Johnny Depp was originally
the the main antagonist oh really and
they ripped him they ripped him off of
it after all yeah Fantastic Beasts and
they they ripped him off of it after all
those allegations and stuff happened
that's like equivalent to like I don't
even think Johnny Depp really said much
like like and he was actually he was
done wrong I mean he got cleared in the
courtroom and I don't think he went out
there and said you don't support this
like for the most part I think he was
keeping his mouth shut so it's just like
look like
and he got money ripped from him it
wasn't the same it was worse and he just
took that like the boss Johnny Depp
I it's just like look man
I feel like you know I'm hoping she
still gets work but it's like you got to
be better on that man you can't you
can't come out there yeah Pirates of
Caribbean he got snatched from that too
there's a couple other jobs he got
snatched for it's like you got to be
better on that you can't just come out
there and say anything you want to like
you got to be better on this so you know
there's not much to talk about on that
you know we'll go ahead and move on with
that because uh uh oh added let me ask
you a question though your initial
question
fifteen thousand dollars
for a Bayonetta franchise
maybe that's a little low
you know my opinion maybe that's a
little low
oh you would expect the main character
of a game with his third iteration of
the game you get paid a little bit more
than that well apparently it was rumor
she asked for a hundred thousand plus
nah I'm not see anywhere of 100. yeah so
he said I do think that
she was being a little emotional but
well obviously she was emotional this
this this has to do with her she has
every right
realistically to be emotional but I do
think that she does bring up concern
that her in the third iteration of the
franchise probably deserved more than
even 15 grand you know I I could see a
world where she gets like 50. yeah and
it's just crazy if you think about it
she's literally the one probably talking
the most and she's getting paid 15 grand
hey hey chat do me do me a number how
many copies does it take to pay off 15
grand with 60 pops someone do the math
because I ain't doing it I ain't doing
it all right so we're gonna go ahead and
uh get this Super Chat real quick the
angry therapist MD set with the five
dollar Super Chat what other Voice work
she done or Nintendo about to body her
bank account I hope they don't you know
I do feel like she's being a little
immature and she probably should have
you know handled the situation
differently but I don't think she
deserves to be in a worse situation than
she was before
I feel like you know she's she burnt
some bridges that's good enough I don't
think she needs the 250 copies
they're they're that's what the chat
says 250 copies to pay for the voice
actor oh that ain't much and that's not
even including the like the the game
like the the what's the word I'm looking
for
the
like the collector's edition or anything
like that that's nothing to do with
those that that's crazy man we're gonna
move on for that before I get annoyed
even more
and that's why I said you know I do
think it did bring up scenarios that you
know they need to do better with
paid actors in general because that
might be one of the reasons that we
don't really get too many paid actors
because they don't pay them so why why
would you re-enlist to come into that
into that franchise when you don't even
really get paid to do it and I I don't I
don't I don't blame them so all right so
here we go with the Xbox series s man do
you know what's going on the the yeah
the 30 frames I heard you guys talking a
little bit about it yeah yeah we're
talking about a little bit of it um yeah
man this is interesting stuff
um I saw you in the chat you know you
were saying some things about it uh it's
interesting stuff man um I would like to
hear your take on it about the Xbox
series that's being blamed for 30 frame
games
all right so I do have a little I did
reach out to someone that works on both
of these platforms
um all right five dollar subscribe from
Donna Taco Bain that I won't have much
voice actors as the previous two games
because there's a new main character
sharing the spotlight I feel you Donna
talking I think Dirk might agree with
this regardless if there's another
person sharing the screen that's
Bayonetta
she's the main person
that's the name of the game
like imagine like somebody telling
telling like Christopher Judge Hey
listen I know you're Kratos but there's
going to be another character and
they're going to get just as much as you
a Christmas just like boy boy it's mine
you better give me my money I supposed
to get paid the most just like hey
remember Iron Man one like the movie
Iron Man one Terence Howard somehow got
more money than Robert Downey Jr
so when Iron Man 2 came around
they was going to change the deal to
Terrence Howard was like nah I still
want this dick and he was like no you
can't get more than Robert Downey Jr so
they gladly replace him with Don Cheadle
like no bro yeah and the sad part is
just like you know some of these people
get a little too full of themselves yeah
they definitely do I think you well I
think what it was dang man you you
completely d-rolled this whole thing
once again
yeah you know we're just gonna move on
but he he done Dera of the the podcast
even a little bit more I I think some of
these people think they can't do it
without them and then the the creators
show them exactly how much they value
them all right so let's get back to the
Xbox you know he he definitely uh derode
that a little bit let me see if we
answered yeah okay
uh so pretty much what's going on is a
developer I think it was from Rocksteady
it wasn't even uh the people who are
making this game for Gotham Knights uh
people came out and said Gotham Knights
to study frames on all platforms and one
a developer not even for the company
that's working on the game came out and
said that it's the Xbox series s's fault
and he he referred to it as a rock or
something like that potato that's a
potato that's what he said potato so
it's just all right
I think we can agree that it's probably
a little bit harder to work on the Xbox
series s
yeah it is there are people and
developers that okay we can't make this
run exactly how the Xbox series X
version is so we'll just make another
another patch or something for that
particular game uh for that particular
console so I talked to someone that
works on both platforms I'm going to
read his quote I'm not going to tell you
who it is uh well it's mainly about the
chat not you dirt but so this is this is
what they said now I'm gonna have to to
he he compared to certain other games
and if I tell you the games it's gonna
it's gonna like tell you what games you
worked on and I I can't have that either
so he said online co-op is hard
untethered Co-op is even harder much
much harder and they said it's
untethered correct
um uh now I don't know how the game was
built or how the engine code is exactly
handling things but I bet having to sync
all the data for the AI game objectives
and object transformation information
will cause a huge toll does that mean
all senses need to be locked at the same
frame rate so that everything has the
same Tick Tock and remain in sync that's
the only way of doing it blank used to
do this that was the one of the games he
used to work on with thinking about that
the one game where the series s does
come into play uh is less memory which
would have a much uh have would have
would make it much harder to keep all
that information synced however there is
a PC Port that will have variable frame
rates across machines and they will be
Co-op the May takeaway is that the devs
are describing is insanely complicated
does come with drawbacks whatever is the
right choice or is a whole different
decision so he's pretty much saying what
they did might have not been the right
choice but you can't really go too much
into that and then he said but I'm sure
they had a they had to make some tough
trade-offs Blake used to do untethered
Co-op and ran into a ton of issues which
is why that particular game has a radius
so look
I think that we can all agree that
this this particular developer on
Twitter I don't I don't think he was
coming out there openly attacking the
series S I just think he's vocalizing
his frustrations with the platform like
having to have them both on the X and
the S but here's my thing
fellow developers do it Dying Light too
and then do it you have no business
complaining about this like it's just
it's your job
at the end of that that's just your job
so what do you think dirt well I
remember when Phil Spencer even admitted
that the Xbox series s will be more work
it will be more work for the developers
um but it is what it is right um
I'm not a developer obviously I don't
know all the the terminology and all
that stuff or what's going on but all I
can do as a gamer
um is look at other games right
um I understand some of the other games
are different experiences they might not
have co-op or untethered Co-op or
whatever but I just see games running in
the 120 frames on the Xbox series S I
see games running at 60 on the Xbox
series s i I don't know man to me it
seems like
um I don't know what personal gravity
has with the console maybe because it is
extra work and you know they don't like
the extra work that is causing those
guys to do but uh I believe at the end
of the day um I think the Xbox series s
has proven to be a good strategy but by
Microsoft and I think it's going to get
better some people say it's going to get
worse throughout the gym
some people say it's going to get worse
throughout the gym I think it's going to
get better you know on some other things
or you know I mean like once the the
sdks mature more and you know like every
every generation the consoles get better
throughout the generation so
you know this is how I feel about it man
yeah it's just like I I understand I do
to a point but it's just like dude
regardless how if you don't like this
just go work for an indie developer at
this point you work for AAA product
that's going to make multiple ports of a
game you know it does cause more issues
developing for as many things as you
possibly can but it's just like that's
where you're going to get some of your
yourselves like the Xbox series s is
gonna sell a lot that's what's going to
pay your salary absolutely
so it's going to sell well it's in that
Soul whether it's going to continue to
sell well so I know some of those
developers you know it's extra work but
hey man
like you said it's your job
we all have jobs I'm sorry what
did you uh
what what didn't he end up deleting his
Twitter or something yeah he deleted or
something I I guarantee Rocksteady or WB
is the low listen man what are you doing
we got to make games for this console
what the hell are you doing what's wrong
with you man
delete all that stuff idiot
this is two years into the generation we
gotta make
this Council throughout the rest of the
generation chill out
it's sad it is and I don't I don't feel
like it's like I don't feel like the
dude himself was like attacking the
consoles I think he was just voicing
frustrations on working on the consoles
because if you are working on like a
hike because I'm sure that for the most
part they're working on the next gen
consoles and their downs playing for the
other console I'm sure he would get
frustrated by working in that kind of
environment but it's like you do it with
PC PC's got like 15 iterations that you
work with a bunch of hours right so it's
just like I don't see the issue and I
see other people doing it just fine and
maybe not just fine that I don't need to
put those words out there but I see
other people doing it and you know I
honestly feel like we're going to get a
60 frames post launch but at that point
I don't care yeah possibly because a lot
of the games was you know like cyber
dying like two they said Dying Light two
a lot of games was able to drop 60
frames per second after launch and I
don't know if you saw the uh cholesterol
protocol official Twitter came out and
said there's some smoke we will have a
60 frames per second performance mode
so I thought that was funny you know
what's funny it was rumored that the
that protocol was going to delay to like
February of next year yeah and they came
out to debunk those rumors and said oh
and we'll have a 60 frame yeah I saw
that yeah like yeah I quote tweet it was
like day one day one and I heard um Plex
tells 30 frames too isn't it it is yeah
it is yeah I can't I can't get down on
that man I'm going to tell you something
because I said this the other day on wbg
last generation I was one of them guys I
really couldn't tell the difference you
know I'm not a PC Gamer I really
couldn't tell the difference but this
generation
I could tell the difference specifically
what Assassin's Creed Valhalla I
remember when they added a
4K 30 mode and like they already had a
60 mode or whatever and I went to that
30. then I went back to that 60 I said
oh I can I can tell now I can tell the
difference so
um plagues tell it's it runs pretty well
um but it would have been better at 60.
yeah so I mean that I think that's
that's all I'm really I see people in
the same attic you refer to the series
that's as a potato I'm sure compared to
the Xbox One X the Xbox series X and the
PS5 it is a potato like like that that's
what you like look
just because we as consumers like the
series s does not mean the people
working on it is the biggest fan of it
you know and keep in mind something like
the series s and X has never been done
ever
they're not used to working on like this
many skus in one generation they're used
to working on a bunch of PC ones which
most PC ports are horrible for the most
part so that shows there how much they
care about the PC market half the time
and then they're used to working on two
platforms most the time now they gotta
worry about the third one as well sure
that it's good for us cheap console
pretty unique way of getting into a
casual audience this is the Xbox series
s but when you look at it from the
developer thing it's just more work and
I'm not saying that you know it's their
job but they still have the right to be
frustrated with their job uh but I do
feel like this person in particular uh
should have chose his words better uh
you know because he kind of gives me
like one of these these PlayStation
Fanboys got a job kind of feeling uh
like filling on Twitter like he finally
got a job as a developer and he called
an Xbox series that's a a potato the
first chance he got but you know that's
still his opinion he can give that
because he actually be making these
games yeah of course but you know at the
at the end of the day even us you know
our jobs like sometimes you know our
boss my asses to do something that we
blow come on man I don't want to do that
so I mean there's things like that I'm
sure people like developers was pissed
off about the PS3 at launch they were
like what is this this sale process I
this is difficult to develop for you
know same with the Sega Saturn so
there's been challenges for developers
before from what we've heard
this is just another challenge man I
mean you know like you said this this
has never been done at launch
before of course last generation we got
the Xbox One X the Xbox One S and PS4
and all that but Hey listen man it is a
different time so
the guy has his opinion he can say what
you want to say but look brother
if you say what you want to say people
will call you out if they disagree
and that's what happened
you're fine
yeah so yeah I think that's all there
really is today uh to say about that you
know I don't think people are going to
be saying something about the series s
because like look people have spoken
against the series s but the funny thing
is the same developers that speak
against it that development team later
on makes a 60 frame mode for the console
that they said it couldn't happen I
remember doing um this Dying Light two
was another one of them yeah yeah but I
remember like somebody from um Ed
software before Xbox bought them was
complaining about the Xbox series that's
like I don't know if you remember
and of course they still dropped to 60
frames per second mode that's what it
seems to me it's just a little bit more
work
instead of just you know doing the Xbox
one I'm I'm sorry that's my series X
version and it's done they also got to
do it as version this seems like this
won't work yeah I mean it is what it is
I you know we'll go ahead and move on uh
because uh we gotta talk about this God
of War coming out really soon dirt I saw
your um
I saw your
do your your prediction thing about it
so uh you know oh yeah yeah I actually
like that man actually you know when I
watch your show I'm a jack that I'm
gonna Jack that I never end up doing it
yet but I'm a jacket but I think I am
going to jack this uh so you know with
it coming out in two weeks because I
have a feeling I'm gonna start setting
up a an Xbox giraffe thing uh I've been
working on it it's going to be a show
that you know I might invite another
person have a team of three and we're
pretty much just gonna like Fantasy
Draft the consoles and I'm gonna have
like a little system in place between us
that we could like cancel each other's
bet and stuff uh so I think that's going
to be fun first off I got to learn how
to play the Fantasy drive because I
don't do sports but you know we'll see
how it goes so all right so God of War I
think we can all agree that that game
for the most part we think is going to
do good and it's 49
49 45.
we're going to get out of here
relatively soon today I'm all for it man
uh it's a God of War guys first off I
want the chat I want you to put in there
do me a favor put in there what you guys
think the Medicare I see some of you
already doing it but I need these
Metacritic scores man I need we'll give
you three but what I want you guys to do
is put three point like Gap like 38 to
what 92 no yeah 92. so that's what I
want you guys to do uh three Gap and I'm
just curious first off what we're gonna
do is just go ahead and see your overall
expectations that you have for this game
dirt
well
um I've never been known before
everybody knows I'm a bot right at it
but I let it be known before I'm honest
guy and God of War is one of my favorite
franchises period so it's a 95 to 98 you
were delusional my friend no I did not
say that no someone in the chat said 95
to 98. no
so you want me to do the three the like
yeah I'm going to say between 89 and 92.
I think yours I think I'm gonna say 88
and 91. okay okay for some reason I
think that this game might not hit over
a 90. might do like an 89 type of
scenario oh
um because I think the places The
Fanboys might lose their mind I already
know people playing it oh really yeah
wow so you know
I think it I think this guy could do
well uh that the question is I have to
you dirt is are you worried about
anything about what you've seen are you
worried anything about like combat you
may have seen how they're changing some
of the element system is there anything
that you're kind of worried about God of
War
um honestly no from what I've seen uh
like for me loving 2018 God of War
now it looks pretty good to me I mean so
far I haven't seen anything that that
like you know like had me raise my
eyebrows like hold on what is this mess
or not I haven't seen anything that made
me question anything at this point
looks good to me so far
I think
that I'm worried about story condensing
okay uh we have Freya as a storyline
uh we clearly have
the the god Anarchy in general like Odin
Thor I feel like there's still a lot of
North mythology left in the franchise
like in this so you said it should have
been three games yes I feel like
this game
should focus on Thor
and the next game should have focused on
Odin and Frank oh yeah honestly I
understand uh yeah but if you think
about it
it should have been three games you know
they said the original
it was going to be another trilogy but
yeah you're right about that and it's
the same length they said the game is
the same length as as 2018's got a war
so that does mean they stuff some say
stuff a lot of content in there right
yeah I see what you're saying I think
that's my biggest concern is like the
same concern I had for Kingdom Hearts 3
there was just a lot of information a
lot of story variables that they had to
tell in one game and I don't know
if that is possible
uh I personally feel like
the game will probably start with you
fighting Thor
and I think they're going to try to do
another stranger's thing
you're going to yank his hammer out of
his hand
and then
you're gonna end up fighting some people
throughout the game and Odin will be the
last boss
um
I I don't know what they're gonna put
Freya in this whole thing and then you
got to look at the Egyptian uh girl
that's in there uh they've already
confirmed she's in the game so I'm not
spoiling anything but
how does she fit in this apparently they
like the game's supposed to go to like
Egyptian next like how does that fit in
this and then you got the the Greek
mythology part of it that they haven't
explained what happened between three
and 2018 yet that's got to be in this
game and then you know they they showed
thought they showed Zeus in Hell fine or
whatever that place is called in the in
2018 so I feel like if they showed that
like something related to him is going
to be in this game I don't know if it's
going to be like him in general or him
in as a you know a ghost or something I
actually think it would be cool
is is somehow if they had three and
somehow after the end of this one all
the Greek mythology gets revived somehow
and the third one is the giant war
between North mythology and Greek
mythology and at the end it's a
three-way fight between you Odin and
Zeus hmm
yeah it's a lot of thing they could do
I'm just worried is there too much stuff
is there too much to to realistically
do the whole storyline in a way that
makes sense that people like and I'm
just worried that they might not do it
I I think that's a valid question you
know of uh
a valid question is especially if you're
into Norse mythology
you know and you know things that most
people like me I don't know certain
things I've heard of you know Odin and
of course Thor but
if you know more about Norse mythology
than the average person you say hold on
man Y'all Gonna force all of this into
one game that's still about 20 hours
long it's not a longer game
it's not 40 hours long it's still the
same length as the first
um one from 2018 is so yeah that's um
that is a valid question and I think
another people 18 is good 18 was
probably
top three of the best games that came
out last year but 18 got so many flaws
if you really think about it 18
got so many people on their Hook was
amazing fighting The Stranger out the
gate and I think that was such a good
hook people forgot about all the
nonsense in the middle hmm uh and it's
just like look like but I'm not one of
those people I'll keep it real I'll tell
you I did not like multiple trolls
fighting the same thing I didn't like
the fact that they they pretty much
stripped the the boss fights in this
franchise there's no boss fights in 18
really there's very few that's true
that's true yeah because like the
previous God of War games has so many
boss fights there is more about how part
three started this ooh there's more boss
fights probably in three hours of God of
War Three than there is an all of God of
War 2018. yeah it's I mean you start God
of War 3 fighting beside him right like
you kick him out of the little water
thing and then just it shows that gory
seen you walking up to him and that
blood's dropping off of you and you just
start hitting him and over and over
again like
yeah
yeah yeah yeah because like 2018 what
boss fights was it he fought the
stranger twice right then you felt the
Dragon
right let's ride the dragon but that's
about it isn't it something I could
think of unless you count like the 3 000
trucks you know I've said it multiple
times that I'll say it again because
it's ridiculous I will never forget
going to the gate where the gate
portal of Hell pretty much they kept
saying you have to go here you have to
go here and they this this gatekeeper
they keep building him up to be this
giant you know fearsome foe it's it's
it's an upgraded troll that can teleport
like ogre troll whatever you guys want
to say it's just yeah the game was good
and I think it was good because of the
presentation more than anything you had
the Valkyries I guess you count the
Valkyries yeah you count them yeah but I
mean they're pretty much just a a a mold
that they just gave new abilities to
it's not like like they were they're not
boss I don't know if I beat anyone I
didn't beat the queen but I beat a bunch
of the little mini ones that was a good
feature though I hope they bring
something like similar like that bat
like 18 was a good game but it was in no
way shape or form better than three I
would say it's better than one I think
God of War 18 is better than God of War
one and that's a lot of that is because
what made God of War God of War I felt
like didn't start really captivating
till two but God of War one was still an
amazing game that's the funny thing the
the key God of Wars none of the the and
people like the uh the the spin-offs
well you know the prequels the sequels
that the main installments that do
people love those but the main
installments of God of War is some of
the best action adventure you will ever
see in the video I agree I agree
especially God of War 3 best action
adventure game I've ever played let me
tell you something when I like like when
I got the Xbox 360 I was content with
the Xbox 360 for years until God of War
3 came out and I said okay I got to give
me a PS3
I finally got me a PS3 Blown Away by God
of War 3.
and that's why I feel like you know it's
okay to have disagreements you know I I
personally feel like the game is
fantastic but I actually think Persona 5
is a better game than God of War so and
that's maybe because I'm more of a
turn-based person so I would actually
Vibe with that kind of gameplay more but
I feel like the one thing I can always
give Atlas is they never abandoned the
turn base they never went to like real
time turn Bay uh real-time fighting like
they did with Final Fantasy with 12.
they never done none of that like Atlas
for the most part is like we want to
keep this gameplay because our fans love
it and we're and we're good at it and
then they're but they're like how can we
make it better and I got to give Atlas
that because square has been downhill
for years to me and Atlas stay true to
themselves yeah hey uh you know I don't
really agree with Nana Taco much and I'm
still not really agreeing with them here
but that Prince of purgatory Trilogy was
absolutely incredible from like in the
uh PS2 Xbox days
uh sands of time was it the warrior
Within
and I forgot the three names but those
games were incredible bro absolutely
incredible speaking of Donald talk we
got five dollar Super Chat from Donna
talking did you all see the post about G
uh Gran Turismo sevens paid suede
reviews if you haven't searched grand
Tours with seven love letter I don't
trust any anymore did you see that dude
uh the people that were saying that they
uh they got black they didn't get
blacklisted by God of War but but
apparently they did Ratchet and Clank
and I don't remember what Outlet was but
Sony responded to them saying we didn't
like your tone the mag um
the Mac the Mac uh I can't think of the
name the something but yeah I saw that
he said they didn't like yeah they
didn't like their tone with it yeah so
PlayStation like yo escapists okay yeah
that's the uh
that's the website that's crazy we've
seen that before we've seen them do that
stuff with Survivor and I've told you
guys I've talked to people that reviewed
Last of Us Part Two I've been told by
many people that is the craziest embargo
they have ever seen in their whole life
Wow like Sony really does be trying to
like like convert these people like it's
because people ask the child no I don't
have God of War
um PlayStation is almost impossible to
get a hold of almost impossible
I don't know I know big PlayStation
people that don't even have a contact
there that that's like one of the like
it seems like to me like they're very
friendly with non-american companies or
non-american influencers but when it's
an American influencer you gotta be like
the top of the cream to get to to for
them to to talk to you uh so it's like
look like what's funny is Paris
literally all has a good relationship
with them apparently and I didn't even
see him posting he had got a war
good for him but it's just like you know
go to work gonna come out well we're
gonna see I I think he said what the
second is when the the Embargo is second
or fourth the second of November yep
so when is that I will all right so we
we are announcing something
on um
so it comes out a week that's that's
good uh a week embargo yeah before the
game comes out
okay maybe I will it's getting a 90
above getting enough a week is a lot
it's a long time oh yeah people people
want us to talk about the availability
so I guess I guess we'll talk about that
uh because you know the good thing about
having two people is we go through
topics relatively fast yeah
all right so let's go and talk about the
valve leak that jazz corn did not leak
let's keep this real right I know a lot
of people were saying it was his his uh
his thing let me let me tell you guys
too you guys know how much trouble he
can get into
if people think he leaked something like
that like he didn't link it so he got
ahead of it pretty fast but
like people got to be a little bit more
like sensitive with that kind of
information like they they were
literally making article say it was his
uh his his leak
yep like he had to make an actual
statement saying he didn't leak that I
know things about a valve that I'm not
allowed to talk about
uh but I think you guys are going to
enjoy it uh for those of you that don't
know there was a leak show that shown
using some kind of magic spell or
something like that it looked good
two years old yeah it looked that good
it looked pretty good yeah
like obsidian this is one of those
developers I think that's their goat
right now yeah like you just trust them
right you just trust them um I haven't
put a lot of time into grounded but I
see how a lot of people is absolutely
loving it it's fun it's fun yeah I love
the outer worlds um I'm definitely
looking forward to about and I'm going
to be honest with you we made fun of
pentiment that's how we say
and watch it be a 90 Plus on that yeah
we made fun of it the the r style is
like didn't blow us away but you better
believe when it drops I'm gonna be
playing I'm gonna give it a fair Shake
I'm gonna ask for a review code like I
think after I need to get I've said this
a couple times I need to be better on
separating the developer from the genre
they make games with because when I see
something like pinnamon or or maybe not
pinnamon it's a little bit like rounded
it's grinder got a little bit of RPG
mechanics but not as much as I'm used to
from obsidian the first thing I think of
is that's not the type of game I want
from them I don't want to play it and I
think I need to be better on that
because these developers are diverse
enough to make multiple types of games
yep exactly and this is all from one
Studio you know so yeah I'm definitely
looking forward to it because um
and now I I'm a topic I would try
any type of game right
um I'm going to try Persona I'm going to
give it a shot even though I'm not a big
turn-based guy I'm going to give it a
shot I just like video games and I try
all types of video games I might like it
I might not I'm not that so far I'm not
that crazy about scoring yeah but I'm
not I'm going to give it a fair shot
we're actually going to talk about
scoring
yeah for those of you that don't know
our topics if you look in the the
description you'll see the topics all of
them because I usually I prematurely put
them in there so I could just change the
time yeah because the time Mafia scare
me so timestamp Mafia I don't play no
games yeah time step I need to like you
know how I have an emote on on a email
it's on IOP I need an email with time
steps yeah what I would do is I would
have like like uh
every time I say time to that Mafia like
right here in on the podcast uh because
it's black up here because I don't have
an overlay yet I just have like dirt
going in like covering me up
uh so yeah we will be talking about
score I think when it comes to avowed
people talk about star Phil people talk
about Elder Scrolls 6. uh people talk
about the outer Worlds 2 to a point I
think so many people are not
realizing that avowed is gonna hit I
think if I was going to hit hard right
and we we've seen time and time again
where
obsidian is hit with a budget like a
very light budget right this game I've
been told has a massive budget it's way
bigger than any of the other obsidian
titles
um you know another one that has a huge
budget is Fable
so it's just like
I think you're going to see an Elder
Scrolls style okay like like success
like Skyrim
uh as long as they do certain things I
do think that it's gonna have to have
huge mod support to be as successful as
Skyrim and obviously they're going to do
that but you know it's easier to mod on
Skyrim I don't know how easy it is to
mod on these type of games so I think
it's interesting man I think that
people always talk about Microsoft's
other Studios but I don't think people
realize exactly first off for those who
don't know you uh dirt you know what
Universe evolves in don't you
uh yeah it's supposed to be in the um
the pillars of attorney yeah yeah the
pillars of Eternity you know how gods
are made in Pillars of fraternity no I
don't they're literally made like it's
like they're fake
like they're they're man-made a lot of
them are there's obviously some are uh
you know I'm probably butchering this
this lower Obama tried anyway you know
if you guys want to correct my lore
correct it in the in the comment section
because I don't I don't 100 remember
everything but what I remember the whole
game
was about proving
uh that some of the gods are
fake and some of them aren't
and if you look if you look at the the
only trailer we have for a vowed
that you know how it hit the banner at
the end
that Banner is one of the people for one
of the strongest Gods like that's uh
where where they they worship her and
what ends up happening is
they pretty much have to
to kill a bunch of these gods and one of
them is trying to prove that they are
God like it's crazy like it's it's
intense just expand on the lore and
getting provide me more fighting options
I agree uh you know I'm not going to
really go too much into the lore stuff
because I I did a bunch of research one
night but I can't remember exactly
everything on it
but I I recommend you guys go look at
the lore there's dragons in this game
there's a lot of stuff in this game and
if I remember correctly it's like I
think I think the gods are fake
and I think the whole point of the pills
of Eternity was to rebuild that whole
thing
uh but I can't remember uh but you know
that's pretty much all we had to really
talk about that uh I think I think
if I was going to do numbers and the
fact that we're seeing this much hype
for about so far I think we might see it
at the Video Game Awards possibly hey
these you also hear because I heard
something about eval was one of the
reasons one of the reasons Xbox wanted
to purchase obsidian it was the only
reason oh okay they saw that they saw
that game and they were very impressed
by it and they bought obviously about
obsidian was bought because of the name
let's be real here they if you guys go
look what's funny is we taught you got
all these people talking negative about
all these all these Studios that they
bought go look at double fine all their
games almost 80s and Buffs almost all
absolutely there's very few of them now
clearly they've made the most so some of
them their hits and misses but they've
made a lot of a lot of hits yeah Ninja
Theory same thing a lot of their games
are highly highly 80s above obsidians
almost never made a 90 Plus 90 lower
game
right so you know
that's the reason they were bought ain't
no so crazy about some of those teams
like you mentioned a lot of these teams
have made great quality games
but none of them had a Microsoft backing
them right double fine I can't wait to
see double fines next game bro
Psychonauts 2 was incredible and we
heard the story that once Xbox acquired
them they were able to put all of the
bosses back in the game because Tim
Schaefer said on the interview Adam
sessler he got to take all the boss out
of the game because it was a
crowdfunding game and you know what's
funny the fact that people will sit
there and they'll say what is Microsoft
done to benefit these Studios when there
was a bunch of content put in the
Wasteland three because of that delay
that Microsoft allowed them to finish uh
the bosses were put back into
Psychonauts too they've already helped
these games and there there's not even
been a whole lot that's done on it
that's that's the funny part of this uh
what you said double fine
yeah what's a gun that they've made
double fine um
Legend
Brutal Legend I like I just can't wait
to see what they're gonna do next just
with Microsoft fully behind them because
I remember seeing an interview with Tim
Schaefer where it like like where he was
talking about Xbox acquiring them and
how much better that is that he doesn't
have to shop their games hoping to
publisher pick it up
he doesn't have to worry about that they
could just go and be creative
and I can't wait to see what their next
game is going to be because psycho
Knights 2 wasn't absolutely incredible
game
and so I think people don't realize too
is hold on I'm rearranging something
real quick all right so I'm putting in
the uh my screen I will get to that
Super Chat momentarily so here is
psychonauts's games
um
you know I'll go do you want me to give
you the link to it or are you good just
me going over the games be fine yeah I'm
looking at it on the screen right now
okay so let me make it a little bit
bigger for you so here's Psychonauts
games uh double fights games
91 87 well obviously you know we'll go
with the middle one 87. then you got 83
79 79 76 84. and what's funny is like
they got a lot of games that they've
worked on 92 86 78 81 90 80 84 84. it's
like I said they've made a lot more
games
just to pay the bills bro that's what
I'm saying they've made a lot more games
than your average person yeah uh and and
even with that the majority of these
like lower Metacritic game is just one
game with all the iterations like so
they they've done well it's just some of
their games for misses and you see a lot
of yellow because those games are
getting uh multiple different uh more
for different platforms uh so then we
look at something like uh the outer
worlds let's let's look at that great
game loved it and you can tell that game
didn't have a big budget either but it
was still a damn good game obsidian
look at this nonsense right
um I don't count DLC because I feel like
DLC doesn't have the I feel like dlc's
just reviewed that it's just a part on
for another game it's not reviewed
fairly DLC that makes sense like yeah
when you review a DLC they're just
reviewing as part of that game that
they've already played and I feel like
it already has to fight uphill because
of that uh so but I mean look at this
we'll go from actual thing grounded 84.
let's see outer worlds DLC then we have
the outer worlds
man that okay pillars of Eternity so
these are all DLC outer worlds 82.85
good good solid uh well 82 for oh that's
the switch 88 for pillars of Eternity
we got 86.85 we got an 80 caught Tyrant
I've never heard of that game Pathfinder
85 then we got some more DLCs pillows of
attorney was at 89. you got South Park
Stick of Truth was anywhere from 80 uh
to an 85 then you have dragon Siege two
I didn't even know they made that game
Fallout New Vegas
what these are all docs follow New Vegas
is that 84 which that's if it wasn't for
like glitches and stuff I think that
game probably would have scored higher
82 82 85 86. uh you know they made the
uh
the Knights of the room uh two like they
they've done a lot like they have done a
lot and I think that you know people
don't really give them the benefit of
the doubt that's why I feel like that's
their best studio
they're they're working bro like you
know how to um it's tonight the second
half for last gen the Coalition was like
Xbox Workhorse it seemed like you know
the second half of last year and it
seems like obsidian is doing that right
now even though some of the games have
been smaller
they're working on their bigger games so
shout out to obsidian
and I've been told the outer worlds two
is closer than people think I think
they'll probably be a year between the
outer worlds too and the fouled really
now let me ask you this do you think of
all this 2023 late 2023
think about it's 2024. early 2024. okay
here because I know hellblade 2
scheduled for 2023 probably Holiday Star
Fields how is scheduled before that like
probably six months
if I were a betting man and I don't know
anything I'm just going off of like
little things I hear I would say you'll
see Starfield before E3 next year unless
he gets pushed back and then like six
months later you'll see hellblade 2 and
then like three months later you'll see
a vowed and then I think six months from
then you see compulsions game in another
three months you'll see uh another game
and then you'll probably three months
after that you'll see uh you'll see
the outer worlds too
and then keep in mind the entire time
they're building this these original
Studios that we're making stuff they're
already probably Midway through half of
the development to their next game this
game yeah see that's why I said once
their game start rolling is going to
continue to roll because like you just
said you a perfect example
say uh uh next year redfall right like
rainfall drops in March
def Loop dropped last year right in 2021
so by the time 2024 hits
uh Arcane Leon might be ready to show
off their next game or drop their next
game you know what I'm saying so you're
right so you're going to have consistent
content
um like Perfect Dark is a game you like
you didn't mention like what is the
Coalition working on right we don't know
what they're working on there's so much
so apparently they're working on the
smaller titles they're not working on
gear six yet because they wanna really
learn how to use
five we got a five dollars for max city
in Union City PlayStation Locker down
Silent Hill why hating on Xbox
Activision though CML literally ignoring
Sony's taking gains from Gamers because
they don't care like CMA they they've
shown that they
I feel like they've been bought like
we're about to get into that here in a
couple minutes you know we'll get into
that a little bit more but I I I'm gonna
be real with you guys I think they've
been bought let's get on to score him
would you play on scoring Dirk
I only played it for like 30 minutes bro
I I you know I played it stopped playing
2K and then next day I know um
I didn't go back to it I'm definitely
going to give another shot because it's
a beautiful game the graphics are really
good
um but you know I got to get into it
like scoring is the type of game you
have to be in the mood to play for me
personally you know I like I like there
are certain games like a Telltale Game I
love those games but I have to be in a
certain mood to play them
um scoring seems to be one of those type
of games I have to be in the mood to
play where I feel like you know thinking
and things like that so I'm definitely
going to give another shot but so far
you know I didn't play enough of it so
what you think about it
so I played about two and a half hours
three played a little bit off stream not
much
I think they kind of fals advertised
this game uh they don't really tell you
what this game's about like they just go
off shock value like the entire time
what I will say is this game has some of
the best immersion I've ever experienced
in a video game I don't get creeped out
in games very often but let me tell you
this game was creeping me out uh if you
get creeped out playing a video game
they have done a very good job immersing
you in that world for you to get creeped
out like that yeah
I just feel like that's all this game
got going for it doesn't really feel
like he's got a storyline with it
doesn't feel like it's got anything
going for it but the immersion and the
sad part dirt is immersion is a hard
thing to get and they got the hardest
thing in games to make really besides
like you know some sound infrastructures
of making games but it's just like
how did how they get the hardest thing
which is to really emerge the player and
play the game but they don't do anything
else like I get it this is one of those
games where it's like
the world tells you a story ain't none
of that nonsense I don't want to hear
none of that nonsense I get so sick and
tired of people telling me to for me to
make the story of A game no they make
the story of the game that's their job
like it's different if you know they say
they didn't they've never came out
openly said that this game was gonna
have like indempsion of a narrative but
so pretty much you start this game you
have no clue what's going on like they
give you like some little vague detail
of like how the game's gonna be played
not necessarily the the the The
Narrative of where you are at what's
going on they kind of tell you a little
bit but not like a lot and I'm just
sitting here like I I put I use this in
a like an evaluation like if they would
have actually
put more time into the story of this put
more time into maybe some cut scenes to
explain stuff in a good way this would
be up there with dead space
and the reason I say that is because
this game Dead Space was good at the
immersion and they got good story and
that's what those two together made Dead
Space Dead Space
this game has better immersion than Dead
Space to me
but the problem is is dead space had
decent fighting uh you know combat
mechanics and they had really good story
elements and this game has neither none
of that and I'm sitting here looking at
this world I'm just like wouldn't it be
nice to know what the hell I'm doing
it's like equivalent in Dead Space for
those of you that play dead space one
and when your girlfriend she she gives
you an SOS saying stuff's going down and
then you go there you're talking to the
mercenaries you get dropped off and then
the game starts from there where you
happen to find things to get certain
parts of the ship running now imagine
taking all that off the game and you
just wake up that that's scoring
so it's just like if they would have
explained why you looked the way you do
or where you're at maybe you're in a
portion of Hell or something it done a
better job like that stuff is probably
in this game somewhere but it's poorly
told
it's just like I see so I always sell
there there were certain games Xbox has
gotten behind or made that had so much
potential they never done anything with
for instance I feel like rice in a wrong
mad potential never done anything right
uh I've always felt like um
what what's the what's the weird game
that people always made fun of with the
with the robots record uh I love record
recore so much potential that Phil got a
sequel I feel like it could have went to
a completely different realm these games
never got stuff and I always felt like
especially recore had so much potential
to be a franchise for Microsoft
this game scoring beats both of them in
potential because I feel like
unlike those other games unlike hell uh
unlike uh race in a Rome and unlike uh
record there's other games in these
genres that do it really well when you
get the horror genre there's only really
like five if that's
that do it well and I think you could
have been one of the top three in those
genre but it's just like you know
I'ma say this and I know you're probably
not going to agree with me
but I'm like man I wish Microsoft would
have backed the truck up for like heavy
funding with this game really because I
know it's
mainly it's probably funding you know
they they couldn't realistically write
because that stuff's not cheap right
it's getting someone a right
full-fledged stories on stuff yeah it's
not but I'm just sitting here looking at
this I'm like man and especially
you know cutscenes cost a lot of money
to make and I'm just sitting here
looking at this and I'm like
this could have been something great
like great but what did you feel about
that little bit you played man I mean
like I said I liked it I just I just
have to be in the mood to play a puzzle
game like that like a game where you
have to you know that's mostly puzzles
um
I will tell you this is this the studio
first game
yeah I believe so yeah I mean that's not
bad wouldn't be their first game you
know um
I'm going to go back to it and give a
little bit more chance but now I'm fully
engaged in um a place to have Requiem so
I'm definitely going to go back to it
later but so far you know it's it's all
right it's you know it it's obviously
not an action game like the Doom or
anything like that but I'm going to go
back and give it give it a solid try you
always have to sit down and be ready for
it so
yeah it's it's their first game it looks
like on their website scoring is only
game that's under projects yeah
um but it's not bad for their first game
though it's it's a really solid you know
first attempt it's just like I'm sitting
here looking at some like you guys could
have literally
had the world with this because because
I'm looking at this game
and I feel so disgust like I'm playing
this game dirt and I'm like I need to
burn my eyeballs out like that that's
how much it's it's just did you get to
the point where you like take the person
off the wall and you're like carrying
around the little shopping cart thing
no I'm not even that far into it yet
yeah that it's creepy so you get this
thing off the wall and you're carrying
it around in a little shopping cart uh
it's spoiler by the way and you put it
in this this machine
and it cuts it in half I did see it on
um yeah on and the only reason you do it
is because you want his hand like this
is so apparently there's another way you
can do to save them but I'm just like
this with me like damn
this has this much attention to detail
this has this much lore going in with
these these hands but it doesn't explain
anything else like why is this person on
the wall like why are you even here in
the first place where are you even going
uh so what two dollar Super Chat from
Jazz uh from Jesh
welcome to Xbox midtober oh okay got
jokes some respect jish
what you playing over on Playstation
that's what I want to know ain't nothing
but on a PlayStation all month you said
October fam you didn't tell me the year
I probably could have gave you the year
but you said October so I could
definitely clown on that what's been on
Playstation October geesh what's been on
play what's been on there geesh
um yeah Jesus right there I'm looking at
you geesh what's been on there October
what's been on there yeah that's what I
thought yeah you jive turkey
uh someone said attic should uh finish
scoring before judging probably it's
probably the best thing it's his first
impressions you know I've never said it
was a review yeah it's First Impressions
saving him is an achievement that's cool
hey Aaron I unblocked you I don't know
why you were blocked because you seem to
be a sensible guy here
I don't know if you're a PlayStation
Fanboy or whatever but I unblocked you
I was after dude last time we just said
uh you were blocked in this chat
I guess I
my mind's must have blocked him I don't
know
but he seemed to be a sensible guy he's
not like like the Eric the beard guy he
came in I don't know if you remember
last time we had to show Eric oh did he
show up yeah he showed up it was talking
trash and of course I said yo man you
got to realize where you are and one of
my Minds blocked him
you get you get you get one chance man
with great power comes great
responsibility no it's it's sometimes
you know even though we talk trash but
sometimes you know my minds and some of
the people that listen to the channel we
need a safe haven away from a pony just
yeah
when you're constantly like I just don't
understand why people go to chats just
to troll like I'm not gonna sit there
expect like I you I listen to more of
these podcasts than you guys think right
I just I never I never say anything in
the chat like rarely unless I'm like
maybe I'm what listen to your podcast a
week or something and I'll be like let
me uh say something that they're talking
about on the chat but I'm just like man
why you guys literally go into chats
just just to try to upset people
it makes no sense to me so let me go
ahead and come in the chat like Xbox
trash like get out of here
I get it though I don't really get it
but it is what it is all right so let's
go and move on to the the bread
and butter of the podcast man uh we
started this at 28 minutes on the dot
there you go timestamp Mafia so CMA
they continue
they're Onslaught man it's it's getting
pretty bad so what
Dirk tell me what's been funny for you
what what things have been funny for you
watching all this unfold
I had to be honest with you my man
before well you know what let's get the
super chat before we go into this Jesus
oh geez another two tell Xbox to fix PC
game pass it's broke
yeah so okay hold up hold up geez
so first you say there's no games to
play but now you're saying to fix the
subscription service to play the game
make it make sense geez and I appreciate
the two dollar uh Jeezy I don't know if
you're trolling or not they do need to
fix the app uh that's for sure but you
can't come in here with smoke and I'd
expect smoke back continue dirt there
you go all right so like I was saying um
I I got to be honest with you lately I
would say in particular the last week
and a half
it's been kind of making me angry
because it almost seems like the CMA is
Sony like some of the things they're
saying I'm just like what it's like that
that me that's like he copied me word
for word bar for bar this is crazy I'm
like hold on man
it just seems like
their main focus is to protect Sony
not the consumer they're supposed to be
protecting the consumer
but it doesn't seem like that I saw that
somebody post something where it said
CMA they mentioned Sony
like
don't quote me on this maybe 20
something times or mention consumer
three or four times like I don't know
man this is very weird to me how this is
happening now I'm obviously I'm not a
lawyer I don't know what happens if the
CMA rejects this because it go into
litigation what happens uh but it seems
like
it's going to be a while man because
this seems like Xbox I'm sure xBox
wasn't expecting this from the CMA it
seems like they were expecting this
they're very smart the Xbox that
Microsoft vary but like one of the
richest companies in the world I'm sure
they have the best lawyers money can buy
I'm sure they were expecting something
some resistance from the CMA and if this
goes to court we'll see what happened
but
um I'm also noticing people just rooting
for this to be blocked of course
but the CMA is on some other stuff right
now I just don't know they're
celebrating hypocrisy I'm actually glad
that Silent Hill got announced
as a 12-month time exclusive for
PlayStation to show that they continue
to do these deals
okay they're doing the deals but come on
man how much you want to bet well shots
just two dollar super travel chess again
Satan I like playing mobile well that's
the problem with you man well there if
you play mobile why you want on PC game
pass right that makes no sense I think I
think you I think I think you trolling
you do really bad at trolling first off
let me just point that out but yeah
you're not making no sense you're making
no sense hey uh Addy let me say this
before you go Chio Walker in the chat yo
what's up brother he said Sony was
mentioned 52 times consumers mentioned
10 times
is it about the consumers or is it about
Sony let I mean you you you're supposed
to be for the consumer
what does CMA stand for anyway I don't
know what it stands for
um someone in the chat if you know what
CMA stands for why Google it you know I
think I can put it but it's like you're
supposed to be about the consumer why
are you mentioning the Sony 52 times
oh competition and markets Authority
competition the markets
I just don't get it this is I just don't
understand it bro it's just like and
Playstation like somebody told me
earlier in the yeah yo look at Country
Music Awards can't make it out
yo okay okay I like these uh hey put
people in the chat put put in the chat
you know let's let's put some fun what
what does CMA stand for if I put in the
chat we got we'll read a couple of them
at the end of the show here's my thing
they it just it'd be feeling like they
it's like literally Jim Ryan gave them a
piece of paper it was like here's my
issues and they're reading almost word
for word what he said like that instead
of attacking scenarios that would make
sense like Cloud you know Cloud uh cloud
gaming or maybe subscription model
gaming instead of attacking stuff that
you could kind of see maybe would be a
monopoly in the future if this deal goes
through they're attacking stuff
that makes no sense why it's a
competition at all absolutely like and
it feels like they keep you know instead
of attacking we can't let them Buy
Activision Blizzard and King because
they will get Call of Duty
they're not attacking well they buy King
they'll have they'll have one of the top
tier
uh King companies they'll have you know
the majority they'll have a good Market
on the PC market and they'll have a lot
of good you know sway things with the
marketing from Call of Duty to OverWatch
they'll be able to use that to to
maneuver themselves overall I'm sitting
here looking at this and I'm like only
the only thing you ever really talk
about is Call of Duty that's it that's
all they're talking about I think you're
absolutely right bro if you were to read
these you wouldn't even know that that
anything else is part of this deal but
Call of Duty
absolutely bro two dollar Super Chat
from the anger therapist C blocking
Microsoft associations
oh you guys are funny guys I I taught
that stuff bro
I just think
I think they're clearly that I kind of
want them to just hit their call their
Bluff say okay we won't sell in the UK
now what
it's just like why don't you tell
your fan base that not only I would
actually go a step further okay if you
think that's the case we won't sell
nothing in the UK none to your
businesses none to your consumers none
to anyone see how quick CMA is like oh
okay Sony you
you don't have enough money to cover
that like but I have a feeling they're
gonna and did you see the The Game Pass
like Clauses they had for game fast with
Call of Duty it said like Years first
off people in the chat who think that
Microsoft would uphold that if they
bought this I don't think they would
like they don't have to go to court and
they'll probably have to pay money but
Microsoft will pay money before that
that will go through
yeah bro they want it in Game Pass even
if they leave it on Playstation which
they said they're going to do they still
want to end their service they spent 70
billion dollars
they want to put it in their service so
I'm telling you guys
before uh added my
my Venom was geared towards place I
would say 98 of my Venom was geared
towards PlayStation Fanboys bro as this
CMA
PlayStation Activision Blizzard deal
keeps we hearing more and more stuff
I I'm sorry to have some this name for
PlayStation because
for this company to be the the monster
that it is for the little things you
would think they're in last place
where they're at bro they're acting soft
they're acting weak they're acting super
vulnerable like they're playing the
victim like no they're gonna take it
away from us is this the same
PlayStation that that beat the hell out
of Microsoft last generation
that went on stage and said this is how
you share your games is this that
aggressive PlayStation no they're
seeming like some punks right now if
Sean was still part of Xbox and he was
leading things I don't think he'd be
saying none of this oh you say Sean who
like Leighton Sean okay if you step on
Playstation yeah part of me feels like
if he never left
he wouldn't be saying none of this I
don't know why but part of me feels like
he would
he would rather lose Call of Duty than
make his company look weak
yeah bro every week right now bro I'm
sorry they're looking weak as hell right
now
uh they could still have the older God
of games throws though no I don't know I
personally feel like it doesn't matter
what contracts say Microsoft doesn't
have to appeal to none of these
contracts it depends on what they get
versus what they what they have to put
if they get more from putting this on
Game Pass and have to deal with the
legal foundations on that I think Sony
is it first off Sony's not going to want
to really
go to court with Microsoft too much you
know right right and it's not even the
fact that they would win or not you know
they could easily win that but it's the
fact that it's going to cost money and
Microsoft's one of the few companies
that can keep them in court for years
absolutely so it's just like you know I
think they'll come to a good middle
ground I don't know what that middle
ground is going to be I think this has
probably been Jim Ryan's you know aim
from the start to cause enough fuss so
he actually has
legit bargaining chips going forward and
and I think you know we can say what we
want we could say it makes them look
weak because it does make them look weak
but when Jim Ryan's looking at this you
know I think uh they did an analysis I
don't know if you heard about this start
where Mike Sony makes
uh Playstation makes more money off Call
of Duty
than all their exclusives combined
um
uh we got a five dollar Super Truck uh
from uh Kiel Walker
I don't know man uh the CM Geo oh so I
did get it right okay yeah see I when I
when I get it right I still think I get
it wrong
the CMA also whined that the new
cinematics games would be uh would be
Xbox exclusives such as Starfield yeah
they want to do man I'm so tired of this
this is It's I'm telling you is that the
point is it's kind of making me angry
and I'm noticing some other Xbox guys
seem to be angry I'm noticing guys on
Twitter that doesn't do console war
stuff or take shots at PlayStation in
the past they've been taking shots let's
just be honest man um
we wanted Xbox to be more aggressive we
want Xbox to you know use their
resources use what they have you know we
want a Microsoft to fully support Xbox
and we we're getting what we wanted for
years now we're getting that
let's stop it how much last generation
did you hear Dirk people say Microsoft's
got all this money they're not spending
it
oh Avatar all the time all the time all
the time and now I'm sorry Microsoft's
done playing with you guys yeah they're
done playing with the industry uh they
heard you loud and clear they opening up
the checkpoint the checkbooks uh and I
have been told
they're not done with Activision
after that they're buying another
publisher
so you know and I was told like six
months to a year ago that they're gonna
a little bit focus more on the Asian
market so I wouldn't be surprised if
those rumors Sega
uh Sega marketing thing I wouldn't be
surprised that that's that's true they
just haven't made any official like
any official pushers I wouldn't be
surprised if there's actual you know
intent to buy offers on people's desk as
we speak that hasn't been signed because
they're waiting for the Activision to go
through I can believe that too bro
the five dollars to drive with the angry
therapist Sony being selfish for their
fan base always talking about support
the devs ABK employees at Microsoft to
buy them they want and need the change
um I actually I'm on the point now where
I'm like Microsoft might end up buying
Platinum Games
because they tell me Platinum Games
ain't been in a negative light for the
longest time they're even looking pretty
bad bro Microsoft loves those uh those
negative light developers because they
look at them as a flash sale we're going
to come in there and pick you up for
pennies on the dollar and fix you yeah
not even necessarily fix you I think
playing a game look playing and games is
a skilled company but they're like
obsidian in the ways where
obsidian was making some lower end games
but their lowering games were still
doing well but for the most part I feel
like Obsidian made better choices by
making some games that was theirs like
the outer worlds and
um pillars of Eternity where those cells
could keep them afloat as an independent
developer if they had to but people
don't realize when you own a company
like uh Platinum Games or or obsidian or
or Ninja Theory like all it takes
because you first off you have to split
your 100 plus team sometimes it's lower
than that like five different ways to
make multiple games at once second off
it's really hard to not look at one game
could wreck your whole team
like wreck your whole thing you think
you're doing good you just made three
four good games
your next game just bomb bombed and now
your whole company's going under bomb
ridiculously yeah you're right about
that man so it's just like look like
that's why I get annoyed when people say
why they buy Exile entertainment why'd
they buy obsidian why ain't they just
making their own Studios you know what
the alternative was for some of these
Studios dirt get shut the hell down yep
there you go and that didn't happen like
Ninja Theory you know
they acquired an edit Theory Ninja
Theory was doing
little small games trying to stay afloat
you know hey yo Chris Hart man you know
I'm a mod on this channel right
what's he saying that's what he said he
doesn't have talking to her oh Microsoft
got caught lying what are you talking
about bro see this is what I like guys
like him is what I'm talking about we
need to save Haven from these guys if
we're up here you know where where we're
having fun we're talking that stuff
there could be times we're not even
talking about any Fanboys so we could
actually be talking and they'll bring up
Fanboys he will come up here Xbox's Dog
trail you know blah blah blah blah
you know the crazy thing about it sounds
blocking my channel
Christopher
you know you've always been a pretty
solid uh you know supporter IOP coming
on there like massive King
but if you don't like Xbox I'm kind of
curious why you're always in Xbox chats
like I'm a little you have to get back
to me on that Christopher Christopher at
first I'm gonna tell you at first Chris
I was like he's harmless
uh but he will come in like
two like every week like he would miss a
episode then at the point my mind
started that he started to irritate me
like bro just like like you know because
I'm one of them guys I read the chat
wild while we're podcasting because I
like to interact with the chat
and you're constantly seeing this we're
like bro let's go to some PlayStation
podcast you don't have to be here he's
on every Xbox podcast I I go to a list
so he's there in the chat like bro but
it's all it's the same you know I just I
just don't get it man yeah ten dollar
super shot from gamer by Josh I wonder
what repercussions will happen from the
deal I think Sony stance is indication
of
of issues that Sony maybe they are
closer foreclosures that we know love
you guys great show I don't think
they're
close to a foreclosure I think that
look
they were making money but I feel like
when you go to
when you go to people who own it because
people always be acting like thousands
of people own all these shares no
in order to to do
what they need done they only need above
50 and a lot of the times it's a handful
of people that own that much
that's all they had to do and that's why
one of the reasons that the uh to do
that is in charge of Activision that
people don't like what's his name
um the code uh Bobby Bobby that the
reason that he's getting a like a golden
parachute is because
he owns he owns all those shares he this
man had a golden parachute the moment he
bought those shares or got them for
working there's no way no possibility
happens where this man leaves without
that money because he has all those
shares
um
something it is what it is you know
we'll go ahead and uh close out of here
because uh dirt he's he's got a he's got
a basketball game I gotta see my Detroit
Pistons lose tonight no they actually
might win tonight I hope they win I'm
just a fan bro you know I love this is
just oh no I gotta be there I'll be and
I do that on my couch is what I'm
talking about I had to be there yeah I
always joke with um
with King and them too it's funny to me
because I didn't I wasn't raised in a in
a in a household that had Sports on all
the time okay so you don't naturally
pick up sports like I feel like you have
to either like young like because once
you're on like your late teens there's
some people that get converted to
watching sports but it's not a lot yeah
like yeah
by the time I got into that mindset
where people would be showing up it was
already too late I appreciate it for
coming out man I'm pretty sure we got
all the super chats yeah we did yeah uh
you know it we I am going to be planning
a special show you know we're gonna make
it a little fun show uh do one week
there ain't nothing going on because
here recently we've been having plenty
of news one thing I will say is I'll be
glad when this uh CMA thing is over oh
yeah because I'm talking I'm done
talking about this like on the real I I
get tired of talking about this but Dirk
what's going on what what do you got
planned man anything planned
uh no I watched a little basketball
tonight after the game probably played
like play some more plays tail Requiem
um that's about it man um I want to do a
video I might do a video about this side
here I'm actually I I gotta be honest at
it I'm tired of doing content about the
CMA stuff I I am because it seems like
it's something new every week it's
literally every week and the sad part is
people can say well why do you keep
talking because we make content on the
subject so it's not like we did not talk
about it it's a big subject right now so
I think I might do a video about the
Silent Hill 2 stuff and you know cool
it's a timed exclusive but yeah
uh yeah that's something that's
hypocrisy right there you know so I just
want I might do I might do a video about
that might not but uh that's about it
brother yeah and then uh catch me on
Twitter at Lord addict IOP go follow me
on YouTube on YouTube guys gaming out
I'm starting to put out almost daily
content I'm gonna try to put daily
content I just got a lot going on and
the the girl I try to kind of have to
balance her too I don't want her sitting
in you know in the room just not doing
nothing because I'm always on my PC so I
got to make it somewhat of uh of a
balanced thing but I appreciate it for
coming through we'll be back next week
sorry about last week I was just
mentally I wasn't mentally there man uh
I I I had no right I had no business
being on a podcast that day I needed
time to recuperate and reset my mind and
I appreciate all for that but I
appreciate it for that thing we're gonna
see you next week talking about the past
present and future gaming piece I'm sure
it'll be some more CMA stuff yeah keep
spamming the chat man keep spamming the
chat yeah I want people to follow dark
check on my channel check out my Channel
please